Who says a video game has to actually work
to be unforgettable?
No matter how many hours developers spend
making a game as polished as possible, some
technical bugs are bound to make it through.
Newer games, like the PC version of Arkham
Knight, may take those glitches to a new level,
but sometimes, the most unbelievable errors
can be found in the games of yesterday.
Make sure to let us know in the comments below
if we missed any big ones!
Here are Screen Rant’s 10 Worst Video Game
Glitches.
Dragon’s Dogma
These days, no triple-A role playing game
is complete without the chance to romance
an in-game character.
But not all games deal with love the way you
would think.
The RPG Dragon’s Dogma let players choose
who would be their romantic target, only to
see them taken hostage before the final battle.
What players didn’t know was that no matter
how many hours spent chatting up a local barmaid,
the game just chose a romance based on time
spent in conversation.
Players were stunned when the final battle
saw a general store owner, blacksmith, or
even court jester revealed as their true love
– the love scene that followed made this
mistake one for the ages.
Assassin’s Creed Unity
No next-gen game is without some flaws, but
AC Unity’s mistakes ranged from tiny to
game-breaking.
Players could laugh when enraged NPCs stumbled
into dramatic cut scenes, but the most widespread
glitch had to do with character’s faces…
or the lack of them.
It eventually became a famous online joke
among players, but no player will forget the
first time they witnessed the real horrors
of the digital French Revolution.
Red Dead Redemption
As open worlds get bigger and bigger, the
unpredictable mistakes become more and more
frequent.
For Rockstar Games western mega-hit, the most
unforgettable glitch occurred when, an animal
in the world wouldn’t be rendered with its
own skin, but appear with a human model grafted
onto it.
The result was donkey women that could be
ridden through the countryside, human beings
flying like birds, and our personal favorite,
the hilarious but deadly man-cougar.
They’re freakish, but Red Dead’s “Manimals”
are the kind of glitch we can live with.
Call of Duty
In the world of Call of Duty multiplayer,
anything that CAN happen, WILL happen.
But players of Modern Warfare 3 were confused
to realize that if a flag carrier in an online
match managed to kill an opposing player,
they would respawn without their head.
That was a funny enough glitch, but the other
soldiers clearly disagreed.
Apparently the horror of the headless soldier
was too much for his teammates to handle:
ANY player who witnessed him without a head
was booted from the game.
Not all battle scars are physical.
Madden NFL 15
Sports simulations pride themselves on recreating
a game down to blades of grass, but somehow,
Christian Kirksey, the rookie linebacker for
the Cleveland Browns was too much to handle.
For some reason, the 6’2”, 235-pound player
was rendered just shy of a foot tall in one
of the game’s online challenge.
Rather than fix the bug, the developers embraced
the tale of the Tiny Titan, and so did Kirksey.
The glitch was taken with a sense of humor,
probably due to the fact that despite his
size, the Tiny Titan still had the hitting
power of his real-life counterpart.
Minecraft
No video game has skyrocketed to global popularity
like Minecraft, where players build entire
empires on randomly-generated and populated
online servers.
But as simple as the cube-based game may be,
thing start to get a bit… weird when you
head to the game world’s borders.
Early players who headed for the edges of
the game’s map – now known as the Far
Lands – soon saw reality itself start to
break, as layers of Earth hovered in the air,
constantly, flowing sand from the sky made
frame rates drop to game-breaking levels,
and every step risked dropping players into
the black Void below.
There’s never been an Inception game, but
Minecraft’s outer limits come pretty darn
close.
Battlefield 3
EA claimed it had a true rival for Call of
Duty when it began to roll out Battlefield
3 for beta testers around the world.
But it wasn’t the graphics, the physics,
or even the game modes that captured the spotlight.
It was a strange glitch that occurred when
players crawled.
One second they were deadly soldiers, the
next, they were long-necked, grotesquely proportioned
human worms.
The developers eventually patched out the
bug in the animation, but as far as we’re
concerned they should have probably left it
in.
Destiny
The developers of this stellar online shooter
may have put hours into the lore behind the
game’s races and Guardians, but players
had other priorities.
Able to make their characters dance, and ride
their Sparrow hover vehicles across the game’s
maps, it was only a matter of time before
the two were combined into one ridiculous
time-killer.
“Sparrow surfing” was every troll’s
dream, but honestly, who would care about
saving humanity from the brink, or taking
on epic Raids when there are enemies on Mars
who haven’t seen a Guardian bust a move
at 50 miles an hour?
We’re surprised the game survived at all.
Grand Theft Auto 5
In game design, ever perk comes at a price.
In the case of GTA5, that meant the decision
to keep every cut-scene playing in real time,
in the real, active game world had a surprise
hitch.
If players triggered a cut-scene while the
police were on their tail, the cops didn’t
back off until their scene was over.
Players watched through tears of laughter
as intense scenes played out as cops fired
round after round into the on-screen figures.
Where glitches like these can break the tone
of serious games, it all fit inside the madness
of Grand Theft Auto, becoming a glitch to
hope for, not one to avoid.
N64 Cartridge Tilting
Modern glitches may have complicated routines
and AI to blame, but in the days of the Nintendo
64, just tilting the game cartridge was enough
to create some instant glitch entertainment.
By misaligning the pins with those of the
system, entire games became hellish nightmares.
GoldenEye turned people into writhing masses
of limbs.
Mario 64 became a limbless jumper set to the
sounds of limbo.
But the Legend of Zelda was the worst.
Forget glitches – the game began to scream
in terror, before a black screen revealed
messages of “I love you” hidden between
lines of code.
We’ll take broken physics over these nightmares
any day.
So what do you think of our list?
Did we miss any of your favorite video game
glitches, errors, or game-breaking bugs?
Let us know in our comment section and don't
forget to subscribe to our channel for more
videos like this one.